le front ukrainien la Russie encore
frappé fort l'Ukraine à coup de de drone
la nue dernière l'armée ukrainienne qui
déclare avoir abattu 26 des 38 an jeens
envoyés par Moscou image ici de
klitivska près de Donesk dans l'est du
pays la région d'Odessa dans le sud fait
également partie des positions visées
par les forces russes le port
stratégique d'Ismaël notamment a été la
cible de tir lancé par par Moscou on va
retrouver à ce propos notre
correspondant à Kiev Guliver Krag
Guliver bonjour vous intervenez depuis
la capitale
ukrainienne racontez-nous peut-être
cette cette dernière nuit qui vient de
de s'écouler on évoque un un flot de de
tir de drone sur le pays he
oui et en grande partie ces drones sont
dirigés vers la région d'Odessa dans le
sud du pays et vers l'infrastructure
portuaire dans cette région ce matin
c'était euh le bac à isacha ça c'est
côté roumain je pense que côté ukrainien
le petit village s'appelle orlivka c'est
un petit bac mais qui peut transporter
des tirs des poids lours je me'y suis
rendu en fait l'année dernière pour
témoigner du fait que il y a un des que
absolument énormes de POS lourds qui
essayent d'utiliser cette manière de
traverser la Danube qui fait à cet
endroit-là la frontière entre l'Ukraine
et la Roumanie parce que les
exportateurs Ukrainiens désespérément
cherchent tous les moyens d'exporter
leurs céréales là le le bac et
l'infrastructure petite infrastructure
portuaire là aurait été endommagé très
très très près donc cette frappe de la
Roumanie qui est un pays membrre de
l'OTAN et de l'UE il y a eu aussi ces
dernierses 48 heures des frappes sur
Odessa les autorités ukrainiennes disent
que 40 40000 tonnes de céréales auraient
pu être endommagé en tout cas un endroit
où ils étaient stockés a été touché ils
disent toutefois que c'était sans
victimes en terme de mort parmi la
population civile h un mot peut-être
Guliver de la contreoffensive
ukrainienne qui se poursuit on est 4
mois après le après son coup d'envoi
oui et les armées ukrainiennes dans le
sud du pays continuent d'avancer très
lentement clairement les attentes
étaient qu'ils allaient percer bien
plusôt les lignes de défense construit
par les Russes notamment dans la région
de zaporiga mais les dernières nouvelles
ces derniers jours c'est qu'ils auraient
effectué une percée c'est la 47e brigade
formée à l'étranger armée avec les
meilleures armes que les États-Unis en
particulier ont pu fournir à l'Ukraine
notamment les les les Bradley
transporteurs les APC Bradley et qui a
déçu je pense et il y a eu beaucoup de
plaines sur le la qualité de la
formation est-ce que c'était bien
approprié mais peut-être que ces
derniers jours ça commence à à mieux
marcher apparemment ils auraient percé
cette fameuse ligne entre le village de
robotiné qui est le seul village dans
cette partie ouest de la région de
zapourija à être libéré déjà par les
forces ukrainiennes et le village de
verbové qui est toujours sous occupation
russe même si certains sources certaines
sources ukrainiennes disent qu'il y a
des combats dans le village de verbové
et et que l'armée ukrainienne serait
entrée dans ce village ce qui si c'est
confirmé serait très significatif parce
que c'est de l'autre côté si vous voulez
de la 3è ligne de défense russe merci
beaucoup guul vercrac pour C nouvelle du
terrain en direct de